this week we're talking about data
storage anthos and eagerly anticipating
next year
I'm Stephanie Wong and welcome to the
last 2019 episode of this week in cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news there's a ton of data out there and
the more you have the harder it can be
to move Google Cloud Storage transfer
service can help you move terabytes of
data from anywhere to the cloud and now
in beta you can even move your data from
on-prem with the same set of tools two
of the biggest announcements this year
we're anthos and cloud run but these two
work even better together there's a
whole bunch of new features like traffic
management and on-prem support that come
with anthos and you can even try it for
free until May next year cloud run is
the easiest way to run containers but
what if your app isn't containerized
it's time to modernize with my great for
anthos which can help you transform your
virtual machines into containers no
matter where they're hosted check out
the guys and try these out for yourself
20:19 has been a busy year we've seen
all kinds of exciting announcements like
the new features being added to
kubernetes and anthos or around the
exciting AI and m/l updates that make it
even easier for you to create your own
models the busiest time this year was
all around Google cloud next with
different talks demos and lots of great
showcases and I'm sure next year will be
even busier on behalf of the team here
thank you for checking out this week in
cloud to stay up to date with the latest
20/20 has so much more to come so stay
tuned if you want to read more about
these announcements or see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us we'll see
you in the cloud next year
you